Since construction of the International Space
Station started to wrap up in the late 2000s,
NASA has had the idea to construct an ISS
for the moon.
Over the years, NASA has received support
from multiple presidents for the Lunar Gateway
and they have sunk billions into the project.
But, just last year, NASA announced that the
Lunar Gateway was no longer a critical path
to the moon.
So, why is the Lunar Gateway failing to take
shape.
Well, taking a look at the origins of the
Lunar Gateway, we’ll find ourselves in April
of 2010.
At the time, President Obama called for NASA
to complete a crewed mission to a nearby asteroid.
Nasa would quickly determine that such a mission
would be infeasible.
Astronauts would have to spend months in a
spacecraft and the technology simply wasn’t
ready yet.
So, Nasa would reject this plan, but ironically,
they would propose an alternate plan that
was arguably even crazier.
This alternate plan was the asteroid redirect
mission.
The idea was that a spacecraft could go and
grab a small near earth asteroid and take
it into orbit around the moon.
This way, astronauts could go and live in
the spacecraft attached to the asteroid and
explore the asteroid over a long period of
time.
Congress wasn’t a big fan of the idea though.
They didn’t believe that the mission was
either practical or useful.
This rejection would lead us into 2017 where
NASA revealed their vision for the modern
lunar gateway.
Nasa proposed a two phase plan with the first
phase calling for the assembly of a collection
of space modules in a distant orbit around
the moon called the deep space gateway.
They originally planned for this phase to
be completed by the late 2020s at which point
they could move onto phase 2 which was the
deep space transport.
The deep space transport was simply a large
spacecraft that could shuttle astronauts from
the moon to mars.
Nasa hoped that assembling this spacecraft
at the deep space gateway would reduce the
difficulty of launching such a large spacecraft
directly from earth.
This plan wouldn’t quite pan out either,
but it would take on a new form.
You see, President Trump would call on Nasa
to not only send astronauts to the moon, but
also build a new permanent presence in space.
The guidelines for Nasa weren’t too strict,
so Nasa would build upon their past lunar
space station ideas and propose the most ambitious
version of the Gateway.
This version involved help from many of the
space leaders around the world including Russia,
Japan, Europe, and Canada.
The gateway was proposed to have 9 different
modules including a habitation module, a robotic
arm, a docking component, and a plethora of
science modules.
At this point, Nasa was basically just pitching
the idea of building an ISS around the moon.
Though extremely ambitious, Nasa was able
to garner support from several space leaders,
so it seemed like the Lunar Gateway would
actually take shape.
But this is when Vice President Pence would
completely redirect the focus of Nasa in March
of 2019.
Pence wouldn’t cancel the Lunar Gateway,
but he would put out a goal that would require
basically all of Nasa’s focus.
Pence wanted Nasa to return astronauts to
the moon in 2024.
Given this new goal, Nasa would be forced
to completely change around their priorities
and timelines.
They would cancel or postpone everything that
wasn’t required to return humans to the
moon.
And unfortunately, the majority of the Lunar
Gateway was not required to return people
to the moon.
But this brings up the question.
If the Lunar Gateway is not required to return
people to the moon, why was Nasa spending
so much money and effort on the project in
the first place?
Given that we haven’t been able to return
humans to the moon in nearly 50 years, you
would think that getting to the moon would
be a top priority and that all distractions
would already be cut out.
Well, the answer to this question is extremely
complicated as there are several experts on
both sides of the argument.
Some think that the Lunar Gateway is a no
brainer for long term human spaceflight while
others suggest that the Lunar Gateway is an
utter waste of time, money, and effort.
So, let’s begin by taking a look at the
proponents of the Lunar Gateway starting with
Nasa themselves.
Nasa claims that there are three primary reasons
to support the development of Gateway with
the first being the power and propulsion element.
The Lunar Gateway is expected to support a
60 kilowatt solar electric propulsion system,
top of the line communications systems, attitude
control, and orbital transfer capabilities.
Nasa argues that positioning all of this tech
near the astronauts visiting the moon will
highly improve the likelihood of a successful
mission.
For instance, even if the astronauts were
not able to communicate with mission control
on earth, they may be able to contact the
Lunar Gateway.
Similarly, if something goes wrong with their
rocket, they may be able to stay on the self-sustaining
Lunar Gateway.
Basically, astronauts traveling to the moon
will have more options available if a major
error occurs with the mission.
Nasa’s second argument in favor of the Lunar
gateway is the gateway’s ability to act
as a habitation and logistics output.
Till now, we have only completed a couple
of manned missions to the moon and all of
them were rather short.
Apollo 11, for instance, only included 21
hours and 36 minutes on the lunar surface.
The short mission durations can be explained
by the fact that there was no long term living
facility located right next to the moon.
Astronauts in the Apollo missions had a limited
amount of food and resources, so they couldn’t
just spend 6 months at the moon.
The Lunar Gateway, however, would make this
possible.
Astronauts could live inside the Lunar Gateway
for several months at a time and complete
dozens of trips to the moon.
Along with this, we have Nasa’s third reason
for supporting the Lunar Gateway which is
its logistical capabilities.
The Gateway would be much larger than nearly
all modern rockets, so Nasa can use the Gateway
for storage and transportation purposes.
Before each lunar mission, Nasa can send a
wide variety of different experiments and
testing equipment to the lunar gateway.
And during the mission, the astronauts would
be able to bring back lunar samples and conduct
various tests on them at the gateway itself.
The ability to conduct tests near the moon
would allow Nasa to conduct many more tests
and be much more flexible.
After all, to get more lunar samples, you
don’t have to launch another rocket to the
moon.
You just have to descend to the Lunar surface
and collect some more samples.
That’s the main reasons that Nasa offers
on their official page about the Lunar Gateway.
But there is one more advantage that proponents
of the gateway often point to which is a transition
point for a martian mission.
Getting to mars takes about 6 months with
today’s technology, so a large spacecraft
with nice sleeping, bathroom, and exercising
facilities would be optimal.
Launching such a spacecraft directly from
earth would be extremely difficult due to
the large size of the spacecraft.
But what if we launched components of a large
spacecraft into space piece by piece and assembled
it in space like the Deep Space Transport
plan suggested.
The hardest part of launching a large spacecraft
is getting it into space.
Once the spacecraft is in space, it’s much
easier to move it around due to a lack of
gravity, air resistance, and drag.
By following this plan, astronauts could simply
fly in a regular cramped rocket to the lunar
gateway.
And at the Lunar Gateway, they could transition
into the large spacecraft to complete their
journey to Mars.
This would heavily reduce the pressure of
trying to build a massive rocket that can
fly directly from Earth to Mars.
Not to mention, this would give the astronauts
a much more comfortable way to travel.
So, that’s the points that proponents of
the gateway bring up.
Now, let’s take a look at the other side.
Some notable critics include former nasa administrator
Michael Griffin and the founder of the Mars
Society Robert Zubrin.
These critics argue that the Lunar Gateway
is not only a money pit, but completely pointless.
Like most space projects, the Lunar Gateway
is expected to cost a lot of money coming
in at $40 billion.
And let’s not forget that space projects
tend to often overrun their budgets by quite
a bit.
So, it would not be surprising to see the
gateway end up costing $60 or even $70 billion.
Something else to consider is that going to
the gateway to get to the moon adds 17% to
the fuel cost of getting to the moon.
Aside from costing a massive amount of money,
building the gateway would likely take several
years.
It took 10 years to build the ISS itself and
that’s only in low earth orbit.
Imagine how long it could take to build a
space station in lunar orbit.
The worst part though is that all of that
money and effort doesn’t even give us any
new capabilities.
Sure, having a lunar gateway would be convenient
for conducting experiments with lunar samples.
But, it’s not like those same experiments
can’t just be completed on earth or at the
ISS.
What about astronaut safety though?
Building a lunar gateway can significantly
improve the safety of astronauts visiting
the moon.
Well, the primary argument against this point
is that we can just build a lunar base instead.
Why spend all that money and effort on building
a lunar ISS when you could just spend all
that money and effort on building a lunar
base.
A lunar base would accomplish all of the functions
of a Lunar Gateway better.
If you’re going to argue that the gateway
is convenient, well the base is even more
convenient.
You can live and conduct experiments right
on the moon.
If you’re going to argue that the gateway
provides greater safety, well the base provides
even more safety.
With a base, you don’t even have to ascend
to the gateway to return to safety or contact
mission control.
Most importantly though, building a lunar
base would be a major step forward in terms
of space exploration.
We’ve already built a massive space station,
so building one for the moon would be more
of a sideways step.
Building a lunar base though would give us
valuable experience that could help us eventually
build a base and city on Mars.
Basically, people who are against the gateway
argue that a lunar base and the gateway offer
very similar pros and cons.
So, why not just go ahead and take the bigger
leap forward and build a base instead of jacking
around with another space station.
As for what Nasa plans to do, though the gateway
has been postponed, they haven’t completely
ditched it quite yet.
But given the strong opposition from credible
experts, it’s very possible that the ISS
for the moon will never end up happening.
That’s not necessarily a bad thing though.
It just means we have more money and resources
to build a lunar base instead.
Do you guys support the lunar gateway?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you guys are excited
to finally see humans return to the moon.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.